good afternoon
i want to thank the president of the
european commission ursula van der leyen
for her visit to madrid to exchange
views
with the spanish government on the
invasion of ukraine
and its impact on the european economy
her effort is an evidence of the
leadership that the european commission
and its president are showing
at this critical time for europe
and it is precisely in these situations
like the in situations like this when
the leadership of men
and women at the head of institutions
are is valued
today it is more necessary than ever to
exercise our political responsibilities
with the vision of the path to take
with empathy for those who suffer
and with the capacity to work together
all these qualities
are possessed by the president of the
european commission
and i want to reiterate this
a female president
because a few days before the
celebration of march 8
it is pertinent to claim the
contribution of women to politics
and i if i have one thing clear
it is that it is a success and a pride
to have a woman at the head of europe
like ursula van der leyen thank you
president
we have a clear diagnosis of what what
happened
the putin regime
sees the consolidations of the political
project like the european union as a
threat
putin tries to weaken
our european area of prosperity based on
democracy freedom and social justice
and that is why he attacked us
the political project like the european
union as a threat
putin tries to weaken our european area
of prosperity based on democracy freedom
and social justice
and that is why he attacked us
but but but i think he's wrong in my
opinion putin has made two strategic
mistakes
the first
believing that ukraine was going to
simply surrender to the invasion
on the contrary ukrainians are showing
determination in defending their freedom
once again we declare our admiration and
solidarity with the ukrainian people
putin's second mistake
has been to believe
that europe was going to divide
no
europe today is more united and more
determined than ever
in the actions against putin
in solidarity with ukraine
and in the response that europe will
give
to the economic impact that putin's war
has cost
we have discussed all these with the
president of the commission a meeting in
which i have been accompanied by vice
president calvinian vice president
rivera
the government of spain has
conveyed to the commission its
resounding commitment to european unity
the implementation of economic sanctions
also in our offer to continue
transferring humanitarian aid to ukraine
as we are already doing
and finally in our absolute availability
to host refugees as spain has always
done when there has been a humanitarian
crisis president you can count on us
finally
we have addressed the impact that
putin's invasion will have on inflation
the price of energy and raw materials
the president knows that high energy
prices are undermining family economies
impacting smes and industrial companies
and generating inflationary effects
as you know the european commission is
finalizing the second second
communication on energy spain has been
calling for
immediate and forceful measures to
question the impact of gas prices on the
wholesale electricity market
and in this sense president borderline
and i agree on the urgency of taking
measures in the energy field
we have received
a review
some proposals that spain has been
defending to stop this period of energy
prices in the same way we have also
need to advance
more strongly in the field of
interconnections
another point in which there is a
considerable alignment is the need to
strengthen the european union's common
security and defense policy
uh because a strong european defense
will be the perfect complement to an
increasingly relevant nato
and i think that the madrid summit next
june will be an excellent opportunity to
underline the complementary between the
defense policies of both organizations
lastly we have exchanged
opinions on aspects related to the
union's strategic autonomy we share
the need to strengthen our industry and
drive technological development in key
sectors
the urgency to diversify our import and
export market through a renewed trade
policy and to speed up the green and
digital transitions
all of them are major strategic
challenges that we
will have to face in the coming months
and years
but i have no doubt that the european
union once again
will emerge stronger from them so thank
you very much ursula thank you very much
president as you will know
um you can count on spain thank you so
much prime minister dear pedro
i'm very glad to be here in madrid spain
indeed is a key partner for me and i'm
here to prepare with you the informal
summit that we're going to have
next week
and indeed first of all we discussed
today the extremely difficult situation
created by putin's war
the number of refugees already exceeds
1.2 million people
and the number is likely to increase
multiple times in the days and weeks to
come
these are innocent women men and
children who are fleeing putin's
ruthless and brutal war
and they need our immediate assistance
all member states are showing a big
heart and helping as much as they can
and many things pedro for the
offer that you
did in our discussions but also here we
know very well that we can count on you
there is a long tradition and many
thanks for that
i also want to commend the front line
countries like poland romania slovakia
and hungary but also moldova for their
outstanding solidarity
they deserve our solidarity and support
as do all european countries that
welcome refugees
the european union is providing 500
million euros in a first tranche to help
ukrainians
and we made sure this week that
ukrainian refugees
of this terrible war get residency
rights in the european union immediately
for at least a year
so this includes not only the access to
the labor market but for example also
access
to
schools access to medical care many
things that are now desperately needed
and let me say how proud i am of the
european union today
our unity our determination and the
solidarity that is really europe at its
best
we have imposed three packages of
hard-hitting sanctions on the russian
leadership
many thanks pedro here too for the very
close cooperation
by this we are drastically limiting
putin's ability to finance this
atrocious war
but putin's war as you said and its
consequences will also impact our
citizens and our economies here in the
european union
and we have also discussed that today
a one of the critical most critical
topics is indeed energy one thing is
very clear
the european union must get rid of the
dependency of russian oil gas and coal
and for that
we have to diversify the supply
we have to get better at energy
efficiency and we have to massively
invest in renewables
because this is a strategic investment
in our security of supply
but also in the health of our planet
and i'm glad to say that spain is a real
front runner
with your impressive share of renewables
and in the national energy mix the
renewable energies plays the major role
with the large lng capacities
but also with the impressive know-how
and the industrial players in the field
of renewables
so spain can and will play an important
role in supplying europe and for that
we must work indeed on the
interconnections between the iberian
peninsula and the rest of the european
union and we've discussed that we will
work hard on that this is one of the
major priorities a second priority right
now is of course
that we need to help the consumers the
households and the businesses that have
indeed problems with the high energy
bills we discussed that intensively and
it will certainly be a topic on the
informal summit in
versailles
diaper this war
unleashed by putin is not only atrocious
it's also a fight
of our democracies against
autocracy
it is a defining moment in our history
and spain knows very well that democracy
is priceless and that we have to stand
up for it
i'm very much looking forward seeing you
at the summit and many thanks for
hosting me this afternoon thank you so
much
you